- People are coming in and hugging now.
And I'm like, "Are we allowed to hug?
Is it over?"
- I think-
- I'm not sure.
- Because I'm back and
forth the UK at the minute,
and we're a bit ahead
of you here in the UK
in terms of like-
- You're the future.
- We're kind of in the future.
- I always feel like a
jerk when people come on
and I'm like, "Here's my elbow."
- Oh, I know.
- Yeah.
You feel like a tool, man.
- No, but nobody's tested more than us.
- Absolutely.
Wait, when you were here in November,
you did something back
in our dressing room
that I found out about later.
And so we have a tape.
Let's see this.
- Okay.
♪ Why are there so many
songs about rainbows ♪
♪ What's on the other side ♪
♪ Rainbows are visions,
but only illusions ♪
♪ Rainbows have nothing to hide ♪
(audience applauds)
- So there's two things.
One, it's an amazing
Kermit the Frog impression.
Two, I am the only human, I guess,
that missed that song in childhood,
'cause somebody did it on "The Voice,"
and the other coaches were like,
"How do you not know this song?"
And I was like, "I missed
this song somehow."
And it's like a huge song for, like-
- That's a huge song, yeah.
- Yeah, I missed it.
- Paul Williams wrote it.
He wrote, like, all the
songs for the Carpenters.
- It's beautiful.
- Yeah, yeah.
- He wrote all the music
for "Bugsy Malone," amazing.
- It sounds like Karen Carpenter.
It sounds like that vibe.
- It does have that vibe.
But my favorite version of it, there was,
that I'm obsessed with this YouTube clip,
I watch it all the time,
is of Debbie Harry singing
it on, like, "Sesame Street"
back in the seventies.
- [Kelly] I've never heard that one.
- It's incredible.
- Okay.
- It's really incredible.
She's like, it's like her
and her absolute pumped,
like, she looks amazing.
She's singing it so cute.
- Yeah.
- It's amazing.
- Oh, I love that.
I know, it was so funny you
saying that, I was like,
"Am I literally the only human
that missed it as a child?"
I don't know how I-
- Yeah, you missed it.
- I know, a breath childhood.
So, can you do any other impressions?
Are you, like, a good impressionist?
- No.
- Me neither.
- I'm terrible at it.
- Oh, my God.
Do you get frightened in interviews?
They always ask me, they're
like, "Can you do an accent?"
And I'm like, "No, 'cause
I'm not Meryl Streep."
Like, what?
Like, I'm just, like, a singer.
Like what?
- But, I'm an actor.
Like, I'm meant to be able
to do it all the time.
You know what I think it is?
- But actors can do it.
- I can mimic, like, I can
do it, like, straight away
after I'm-
- Me, okay.
If somebody does it, I can do it, yes.
- And if I'm doing it for a job,
and I've had all months to
prepare, yeah, sure, of course.
But, I can't just, like, jump
into it like some people can.
- Well, it's so funny 'cause to me,
you have just such a thick accent.
So I'm like, that must
be hell to try and lose.
- Yeah.
- I have a thick accent, so-
- Yeah, it's nice the last
couple things I've done,
"Belfast" and "The Tourist,"
I got to use my own accent.
That's much, much easier.
- It's a cool accent.
You should just use it all the time.
(audience applauds)
You have a very musical household,
your wife is a composer.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I remember you were
telling me that before.
So do you sing, do y'all sing,
or is it a very musical household?
- Yeah, I sing too much,
I think, around the house, you know.
I'm one of those people-
- She's like, "Shut up."
- I just, I have a vast energy, I guess.
I'm not very good at being
still and being quiet.
So, I'm always in the
house running around.
It's a musical house, right?
We've got, like, a couple of
pianos in there, a few guitars,
and the kids are now starting
to learn to play instruments.
But, I think I sing a lot and I feel,
and I don't realize I'm doing it.
So my wife will be,
like, been in the kid's
and she'll turn around,
like, "Are you serious?"
I'm like, "What?"
"'Cause you've be singing the same line,
like, over and over."
- Oh, you don't know the whole song?
- Often not, you know?
(Kelly chuckles)
But, like, none of us, like,
there's probably only about
three songs in the world
I know all the words to,
do you know what I mean?
- And they're all from, like,
junior high for some reason,
like, for some reason we were like 13,
we could memorize songs and then no.
- Yeah, mine's like Weezer
and stuff like that.
- Yeah, Weezer, yeah.
- Yeah.
- "Say It Ain't So."
Oh, my God, they're a great
band live, by the way.
All right, we're back with
Jamie Dornan, y'all give it up!
(audience applauds)
All right, that was a look
at his new HBO Max show.
The new show is called "The Tourist."
So, explain to everybody what it's about.
- So, we find this guy, me,
driving through the Australian Outback,
and he's in this little old car,
but he's happy, he's singing along to,
and then he gets involved in
this very intense sort of race,
sort of hunt with a a big truck.
Truck hits him off the
road very deliberately.
He wakes up in hospital
after this massive accident.
He has no memory.
He doesn't know who he
is, why he's in Australia,
why anyone's trying to kill him,
and then we basically spend six hours
meeting these insane people
and piecing together who he
is and why he's in Australia.
- I feel like you're in everything good.
I love everything.
And by the way, you look-
- No, I'm not.
- You are.
- Definitely not.
- And you look like a
completely different human
with that haircut.
- That's what's nice about it, you know?
I shot it straight after
"Belfast" where I'm like,
I clean, I'm shaven, and all very neat.
- Who the hell is that, yeah?
- And then I'm that guy
shaved head, big beard,
and actually, as we kept going,
my beard just got bigger and bigger,
and more gray.
Like, it's really gray on my beard,
which is, I'm okay with.
- That's cool.
Being okay with it, it's cool.
- Yeah, we're both-
- Women don't like a dyed beard.
And if they do, they're fake women.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- Yeah, it's weird.
- Never dye your beard.
- I know, I always see men
with, I'm like, I just, yeah.
"Did you, was it the box?
Did you get it at the box?"
I'm like, "What did you read?
Did you brush it on?"
Like, anyway, it's okay
to be gray, we like it.
- Totally.
- So, do you like shooting in the Outback?
Because I have several, I've toured there,
and that can be, like,
an interesting dynamic.
Like, everything happening there.
- It's a hostile environment.
It's not easy.
- Yeah, if you're doing outside shows
- We were, like, dust storms, like,
between all of the shots that
day, particularly that image,
you know, between shots, we're
all wearing these fly nets,
you know, the flies are rampant,
and I swallowed plenty of flies.
Like, really did.
Like, during takes,
I'm, like, trying to act
and there's flies, like,
crawling into my mouth inside.
- Yes.
- I'm like-
- Perth is the worst.
- "Swallow it and move on."
- Yeah, awful.
- I don't know where y'all were.
- We were in, sorry, pretty
sure it was Adelaide.
I don't wanna put people
off going to Australia,
'cause it's a great place.
- I love Australia.
No, I will say too, it's literally,
that's part of my favorite
place to go outside,
I felt like it was one of
the first places I went
and I'm from Texas.
I feel like it's a giant Texas,
like, everyone's so friendly.
- Right, right, right.
- But the flies are,
they're out to get you.
- It's a real thing.
- And they're gigantic.
- They're huge, aren't they?
- Yeah.
- They're hungry and they're angry.
- Yeah, I'm like, "Oh, my God."
But that's, yeah, dust
storms, I can't imagine too.
Like, having to do takes and
your eyes are probably dying.
- It was a lot, you know,
for every department.
Everyone's got sand, the dust
getting into cameras and,
you know, it's not an easy, like,
if you're in this nice
controlled studio environment,
your job's much easier.
Like, but it was tough,
but it was rewarding.
- So I heard that your
daughters were impressed
that you got to meet the guy
who made "Encanto." (chuckles)
- Well, listen, so we had the SAG Awards,
and we'd spent the whole
Sunday morning with the kids,
and then had to go pretty early,
start getting ready for the SAG Awards,
and we're like, "Mommy and
Daddy are going out tonight."
And they're like, "No,
no, we don't want you."
Anyway, the whole meltdown.
We're like, listen,
guess who we might meet?
And they're like, "Who?"
We're like, "Lin-Manuel Miranda."
And they were like, "No!"
And I was like, "Yeah, we'll see."
Anyway, so we go to it, and
Lin-Manuel comes up to me,
and is like, well, he's with,
Andrew Garfield is one of my best friends.
Obviously they worked together
on "Tick, Tick... Boom!"
So Andrew brought him up
and Lin basically had seen
this movie I did called
"Barb and Star Go to Vista Del Mar."
He's seen it over 10 times.
So he was the one coming up to me.
I, like, blew my kids' mind.
We're obsessed with him in the house.
Obsessed with "Encanto."
- Oh, my gosh.
- Obsessed with "Vivo."
Like, obsessed.
- So, I think any-
- "Moana."
- Yes, any person with children,
you know, Bruno, you know all this,
like, "Tick, Tick... Boom!"
You know all the songs, yeah.
- Constantly.
It's on at home, watching it-
- And then in your car.
- And in the car.
It's the soundtrack.
- Yeah.
But I'm fine with it.
- I am too!
- Really good with it.
- And I should hate it by now.
- No, you can't hate it.
- I should seriously have a loathing like,
Tim McGraw, "Don't Take the
Girl," back in the nineties,
they played that song too much.
I should have, like,
a kind of a hatred for it
at this point, and I don't.
- But that's a measure of
how good the songs are,
that they don't grate on you,
even if you hear them all the time.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it's kinda cool too,
like, to be that talented,
to impress people with Hamilton,
adults, make grown people cry,
and then touch kids like that.
That's a rare talent.
- The guy's a proper genius.
(audience applauds)
- But I love that he was,
like, impressed by you.
That's a good feeling.
- I would say it was great, it was mad.
- You're like, "Wait,
you're impressed by me?
Okay, I've done all right."
- Yeah, exactly, yeah.
- I love that feeling.
So the last time you were here,
I gave you an early birthday gift,
a Whataburger.
- I loved it.
- Be honest, you loved it?
- I did love it, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, it's a good burger.
- So, I'm planning
something for you today.
- Okay.
- A little bit of a-
- [Kelly] Okay.
Look at me going in on that.
(Jamie laughs loudly)
I was, like, "I don't care that
I'm on national television."
- I love that, I love that.
- So what?
I like your burger.
I'm gonna, it was a big bite.
It was a big bite.
What did you bring me?
- I brought you this,
so where I come from,
specifically in Northern Ireland,
we used to have the stuff,
it's basically, like, dried out seaweed.
But it's not like those thin seaweeds
that you get in like posh delis and stuff.
Like, it's very from the sea.
It feels like someone's just come
and picked up some seaweed, shaken it off,
and put in a bag.
But, it's called dulse.
- Dulse?
- Dulse.
- No, I like seaweed.
What you just described
doesn't sound great.
- It's a-
- I like the thinly, like,
"Oh, Himalayan salt."
- No, it's organic, like, put it that way.
Its like-
- It's that kind of organic.
- It's that kinda like-
- Aquaman from the sea.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, no, no, I like this, I've had this.
- Oh, you've had it?
- Uh-huh.
- Oh, look at that.
- No, I like this.
You just made this sound horrible.
(audience laughs)
Like, this is a perfect amount of salty.
- I'd say I grew up having
the sort of gnarlier version
of this, I would say,
where, a little bit more...
This has gone through a bit
of work, I think, you know.
To get to this posh.
- No, I like, these are good.
Like, especially if you want
a chip, but you're like,
"God, don't be so fat, don't eat a chip,"
and then you, like,
get this and it's good.
- But then you kind of sissy,
then you open a bag of chips anyway.
- Yeah, oh, my God. (chuckles)
After a drink or two.